taking your calls let's go next to our
caller from the 201 area code caller
from 201 introduce yourself tell us
what's on your mind today
David big fan I'm John in New Jersey
first time caller got a question for you
buddy okay go ahead
after watching the bigoted right-wing
religious nut Roy Moore when the Alabama
primary yesterday yeah any possibility
of you guys doing an extended piece on
the supposed separation of church and
state
that's purported to exist in the United
States that's a good topic for a
long-form piece it's not on our list
right now but if the audience demands it
I would I would I would have to go with
that because that's a major issue what
really are the limits of that separation
what have been the attempts to break
that separation and what was what truly
was the intent of the framers of the
infrastructure of the United States
right when it comes to separation of
church and state yeah I mean what I've
not followed Roy Moore super closely I
know that he's a religious right dude
but is there something in particular
he's doing that sort of anti separation
of church and state
you might recall he's the guy who's the
Ten Commandments guy the First Amendment
only protects Christians right correct
Yeah right yeah not exactly strict
separation of church and state I would
say bingo yeah thanks David all right
thanks very much John appreciate the
call yeah Roy Moore right Ten
Commandments guy and the entire thing
we've got we got to do a piece on that I
like that idea